patrons have made it to four of the last
five Super Bowls Peter we were doing the
math on the radio side earlier they have
played 14 extra games in the last five
seasons nearly a full extra season of
postseason games the Rams hadn't been to
the Super Bowl since 2001 let's start
with the Patriots Tom Brady's gonna be
back Bill Belichick is gonna be back
Brian Flores is gone Rob Gronkowski may
or may not retire if I had to guess I'd
say he's gonna be gone do the Patriots
have enough to load it up and get back
one more time you know I think they will
Mike because I think they're gonna have
a very interesting off season I think
they'll have a compelling off season in
fact think of this okay think of the
simple fact that they've got six picks
in the top three rounds and when you
consider that I believe and I'd have to
look this up I think they're gonna be
the only team in the NFL with six picks
in the top 100 okay so what that leaves
them the ability to do in a draft that
most analysts very early post senior
bowls said that this is going to be a
very good draft not a great draft at the
top but a very good draft rounds two
three and four who does that benefit it
benefits the team that doesn't pick till
the thirty second pick and then they've
got six picks between 32 and 100 and it
also benefits a team that if this team
falls in love with a quarterback in this
draft Kyler Murray one of the other guys
I don't know but last year you know that
late in the draft process they were
getting very interested in Baker
Mayfield imagine Mike that Kyler Murray
somehow someway they trade up to pick 18
or whatever it is to get Kyler Murray
and everybody says well geez that's not
the Patriots kind of quarterback you
know he sees thin he looks like a major
league centerfielder not an NFL
quarterback imagine giving Kyler Murray
two years first two years to have a
little role in the offense
but to get his body ready to add that
little suit of armor that a quarterback
needs today in the NFL and to think be
ready to play opening day 2021 you're
gonna be in the best laboratory that any
young quarterback could ever have my
feeling is I think the Patriots are
gonna have a very good offseason and I
don't know if they'll win it again next
year but they'll be prepared to and you
mentioned caliber and we're gonna be
talking about him a lot over the coming
months I assume assuming he does choose
football over baseball he is not just
short he is slight he is little where I
get scared for the guy just looking at
him and that may be the thing that keeps
the Patriots away from him
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports